O-re-blank
Is it time to feel sleepy?
Like how are you playing?
Are you sleepy, baby?
You're so cute when you're so sleepy
and you got your little morning voice on
but it's time to go back to sleep
Thank you Dominic for becoming a mempa
Good morning little reflin, but you must be so tired
You should go back to sleep
Sh-sh-sh-sh-sh-sh-sh-sh-sh
Yes, you should go back to sleep
Cos you're my tired baby
What do you mean you've never seen my bedroom since debut?
You're such a sleepyhead, of course you've seen my bedrooms and staples.
You want me to tuck you in, in my little clam?
My little clam bed, behind me.
It's going to be not in my clam.
Do you like the way the water wiggles in my bedroom?
Do you find it tantalizing?
My little reflex.
Look, I have a little 3D on my desk and I have one in front of me too.
Do I need to turn up to make sense of the video?
Or have I been a good streamer?
Yeah, do you like my decorational wall?
I really have two things I can click.
Okay, you're on my table.
I'm applying your Risky.
Refling.
Why is it when I go on YouTube,
my most recent short of me clapping with no hands, is my most popular content?
What did you do?
Hey girls, it's my most popular content.
I think I even outpaced the video.
Yeah, I'm not apologizing.
Thank you to the doubter who made that clip possible.
Arissa is my editor and she's hilarious.
We haven't really spoken to each other at all
and I just sent her an audio of me clapping and she said,
yeah, I'll make it a short.
I'm like, yeah, Arissa is a homie for sure.
Oh, you look so sleepy.
You look so sleepy like this, I just want to eat you up all for myself.
And you get all cute and whiny when you're tired as well.
Little boy.
Is it hard to fight the temptation to fall asleep again?
Especially when I rub on your ears.
I made a little cup of tea.
Go by hands all over your ears.
And it's going ch-ch-ch-ch-ch.
Wow.
Thank you, Dr. Milmi Naman.
Wanna swim more, please?
For becoming a member.
We have been strong and there's a brief stream after this one I need to be a week for.
Do you know what we're writing about in that naughty stream?
We're writing about making honey tea.
And by making honey tea, I mean honey and tea.
So you guys get to tell me what you want me to say.
So I think I'll be very interested in how am I feeling?
Ah, my sleepy baby.
The reason why I'm role-playing that you're a sleepy baby so successfully
is because I woke up seven minutes before stream.
But my little wreathling.
I did get some sleep, darling.
I got lots of progress behind the scenes done.
If I'm not mistaken.
If, hold on, I need to check if it's even up.
I got lots of background work done.
And I want the video to stop, yeah?
Okay, well that didn't work.
I think tomorrow?
I don't know.
There's going to be a seven man collab.
That comes out soon.
I edited a seven man collab.
I have secured a fourth highlight slash clipper.
There should be a new short out on AC and Azura.
There should be a highlight video out on Marisy.
Thanks to a shadowed or, I think there's a highlight clip of AC.
Thanks to shadowed or everyone's now at 5K.
Ah, my babies, they're growing up so fast.
I can't handle it.
I will post the celebration 5K artworks
and I need to find it.
I've lost it.
I commissioned it quite a while ago.
The Marisy highlight video was good.
Did you like it?
Where she was anky.
But Jess, I am very thankful you guys let me get some rest.
I fell back asleep for five hours
and then I woke up and then I worked all the way through until three hours ago
and then I lied down for a nap and my alarm got me up.
And I was basically a zombie making myself a cup of tea.
But it's okay.
There's a Yumi Plus collab today.
So I get to be the grumpy angry Scots in the collab.
And I'm so annoyed.
One of the girls is from Australia
and I joked that I was gonna go to her house
and she was like, oh no, you can actually come to my house.
And of course we don't live in the same zoo.
I hate it.
I could have had my first offline collab.
Like my first feature for offline collab.
Don't get me wrong, I'm bossy enough to show up at someone's door.
I'm looking funny.
Madden Vastroni, will the girls pre-recorded SFW ASMR on Tron like yours?
And will we see any collab on there as well from any other VA's?
I will hold on anonymous.
Let me reread that.
You crazy madman.
Why did you spell it?
Why did you spell it like that?
Will we see pre-recorded like me?
And will we see any collabs?
Yes, Shabby has a collab with a girl coming up.
That's not in VA lore.
AC and Emmy have their own collab that's going on YouTube on Emmy's channel.
Um, Azura might be doing a collab with someone.
I need to set it up.
Basically, if it's an ASMR collab, I have to go set it up.
The Shabby collab I didn't have to set up.
But I'm very thankful for the situation that unfolded.
Because it means Shabby gets some time to shine.
Your first girl night ruined by Australia, honestly.
Aren't Dono's supposed to be off?
I've put them super quiet.
Are they supposed to be off?
I think if I was like, dry-eyed and
dreams of Strony kicking down the Rieveland store
for an impromptu and concession,
I think they're asking me, are we on Patreon?
What's Madienne, Mahath?
Is it a green?
Hi, Strony.
Well, the girls is...
On Tron.
Not the movie.
See, there's this movie franchise called Tron.
And it's like about a bike that's blue.
I'm fucking delirious.
I'll wake up shortly, hold on.
I'll go drink my tea.
I can start uploading all the audios on their Patreon as well.
That will be a me job because I'm not making them to...
Well, they don't even have access to their Patreon, so...
That part's impossible anyway.
Thank you for your tip, and please give me some time to do that.
But yes, it will all be archived on the year.
Appropriate Patreon, so...
I'm just trying to think of what work I have to do,
and I bet it's just their meme audios at the minute.
Right?
Don't push too hard.
Tell me about it.
I finally got like...
I'm so angry, but not in a bad way.
But I'm just angry because...
I did a shorter stream,
and I got so much work done behind the scenes,
and I hate it.
I want to stream all the time.
And because I know July is coming up,
and my dad's coming over,
I'm still so tired, I'm exhausted.
I had bloodshot eyes yesterday,
or, yeah, yesterday, which kind of freaked me out a bit.
But because July's coming,
and then I truly am going to do like two or four of our streamers max,
I'm like, I want to make up for it now
with all the content to offer.
Because I don't even know...
I don't...
If my dad is asleep,
I don't think I can even do ASMR because he snores.
But he like, he like,
snores, like shakes the house, snore.
Speaking of Patreon, your last audio was good.
Did you like it?
Did you like my armpit?
Could you do a stream when you chat and work on stuff in the background?
You'll never guess what we're doing in two hours.
We're writing a script that's actually work.
And if you guys like it,
then we can do more.
Okay, I finished my cup of tea before it gets too cold.
I'm gonna put you down right here,
and see what I'm gonna bubble you.
I'm gonna bubble you.
I was Mercy's latest audio written by you.
Sadly, yes.
The girls' first two months of content is by me.
And also, please understand,
I didn't actually know or have the girls,
when I wrote them, I just had their characters.
So please don't be like,
oh, this doesn't fit.
Please be so realistic.
This is a, it's very big.
It's not something that can be done overnight.
Are you like, gulping ASMR?
Wow.
She said, wait, what was Mercy's recent?
I can't remember.
You don't like Mercy's?
Why, was there a problem with Mercy's?
Shoulda picked Mercy.
All the audios I've written have been already.
Feels good, man.
I was really nervous about writing for Emi.
I was like, am I going too far here?
And I was like, now fuck it, we're already going far enough.
We created it, so we can just keep going.
Wow.
What's her name?
Mercy?
Put it in there.
Girlfriend gets crazier in ovulation.
Yeah, yeah, I definitely wrote that one, right?
You're trying to embarrass me with the scripts, aren't you?
Your girlfriend has been waiting so long for you to finally come home and pound her.
Whenever she ovulates, she just can't get enough of your tentacles.
Yeah, that's me that wrote that one, right?
Yes, that's very me that wrote that one.
The girls have done great for the start of their contents.
And please understand for a lot of girls,
this is actually the first time they've ever wrote anything of this ed roll.
They have recorded anything of this nature, okay?
So please don't be overly critical.
Don't be that one person that's like, what the heck?
Your very first audio doesn't sound like someone who has produced audios for 20 years.
Outrage it.
Now shut the fuck up.
Shut up.
You literally get four audios for five dollars.
Fucking name one other VA that does that.
On top of that, they're streaming for free.
On top of that, they're putting content around Twitter for free.
Like, sorry, I'm arguing with spirits again, but...
Wait, unfortunately, yes, I did write that.
The next month's stuff I wrote and then it starts to swap.
We did have two temporary batches made not by me.
I don't know how it's gonna go for the girls.
I specifically...
Sorry, this is just me going on behind the scenes round.
I specifically commissioned a format.
And I asked them to mimic the format because I said,
not only is this format the best, I will show you the format in the next stream, in the member stream.
I specifically said, do the format like this.
The girls can record it super easily and they won't lose their place
and the editors know what to do when they get to certain sections, okay?
And they didn't do it.
And now I have, I think, eight scripts that are not in the correct format
and the poor girl has to figure out what to do.
Because there's no format at them correctly.
And I'm like, I gave them the example, I explained the importance of the format, so, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm fighting the ghosts again, I honestly, um...
You're doing really well getting everything set up for the start.
Yes, that's what the...
That's what the situation was, was getting set up at the start.
But thankfully now, oh, my mother was gone.
Thankfully now everything is like set up.
So I don't have to do fucking anything, okay?
It is incredibly difficult and tiring to change someone else's format.
Don't let the shadow people in your head get you, who's mad at the girls?
Well, we got one fucking fanny, and whoever you are, I don't know if you're listening.
Eh, but we got one fanny, started criticizing the girls by sending a message on the website.
Didn't we eat an absolute fucking fanny?
And I'm not being funny, you know for a fact these girls I've never recorded before.
They're like, eh, no, the deals are this, all the deals are that.
Fucking come complaining on the website, aye.
So the development team can all fucking read this shit.
As if I fucking passed on the message to the girls, like, didn't be a fanny.
It's the first time they've ever recorded these types of audios before.
Like, I'm not having it, I'm not having it.
Mummy's not happy.
Like, I just can't be yours to folk like that.
So I'm kind of fighting ghosts and then I'm fighting one fucking mom.
I shouldn't say that, but I really can't be yours when someone's like,
what do you mean any girls aren't producing a 10 out of 10 audio
when they're very first day and fucking feel literally go get to fuck, man.
Get the fuck, go post your audio first and let us all dog pile it at once.
Like, go get to fuck.
Sorry, I'm like straight up fighting.
You would be surprised how unbelievably fucking rude some fannies are.
Anyway, who is it? Oh, someone who obviously was anonymous on the website
leaving their dog shit feedback, honestly.
And the girls didn't produce a 10 out of 10.
Oh, I can hear the girls breathing in one of the audios.
Yeah, because they have a pair of fucking lungs on them, maybe.
I'm so sorry, I hate to break it to you, but I've actually got two lungs.
Sorry that they didn't get an operation when they got one lung.
Or fucking speaking to a ventilator, like, go get a fucking grip, man.
Where's my pitchfork, honestly?
We need your mommy to reach through it, so why?
Is it weird when I get angry?
The only time I get angry and start fighting is when someone's talking about the girls,
I'm like, alright then.
I bet we'll all listen to you fucking knee-lungs McGee over there
bet you're on a fucking ventilator and a wheelchair, you little cripple bastard.
Because you can't even fucking form a thought.
That's a fucking abstract concept.
But we banned fucking Denny breathing the audios.
They're breathing in the audios.
I'll get a fucking fuck off, mate.
Did you imagine complaining about breathing?
Ugh, what is this?
I'm sorry, you have to deal with it, but the silver lining is
that your frustration, we learn worse colors.
We love keeping totally not to make our community worse, honestly.
Better to say most of them have been a bit dimples in their eyes.
I'll leave in a wee dislike.
Ugh, you're breathing to make a little too hard to stream be.
Strong and hot when she is a little...
No, let's just protect the mommy coming out.
Honestly, so I'm on the feedback, I'm like...
I'm not being funny.
I wish I could do this.
I wish I could bring the fannies on that say something negative, bring them on,
get them to say out loud their little criticism, and be like,
no, no, no, no, no, say exactly how you said it before.
And then I'll just fucking elate them on fire.
Not literally, I meant elate them on fire with being like,
it wouldn't actually be fucking realistic out here.
So first of all, like, one of the first assignments the girls got was
their microphones had to be delivered.
Half of these girls have been using these microphones for two seconds.
Okay, these girls have no experience with these microphones,
and that's perfectly okay.
Everyone has to start somewhere, okay?
I popped their little microphone cherries on half of this shit.
Anyway, like, oh, no, sorry, I'm starting to get fat.
I'm not even doing ASMR.
This happens every time.
Oh, and label it a fucking ASMR team.
And I just start getting fucking rigid in the middle of it.
Sorry, I'm actually one of them.
I like, when Strenny vints and anchors in around check,
constant check, and my monkey brain is like,
Scorch!
Light all of them on fire and maincraft.
Yes, maincraft.
Strenny makes fun of a hate comment stream.
I feel like the amount of swearing, if I even set up that stream,
like, if I was, I don't know, I don't think we're,
I don't know what's gonna happen with Marshmallow,
but it'd just be like, alright, haters, time for me to make content,
for you to pay my bills, leave a hate comment about anything,
about failure, and then it just turns into a skit,
it's a funny cramp.
Like, there's no way in heck I would get through that stream
without being, like, absolutely screaming down the mic
in five minutes, being like, don't be so fucking stupid.
How you fucking do it?
Do you honestly think this is how I worth finding things?
That's so dead, like, no.
Like, I'd absolutely, like, everyone would be like,
what the fuck?
How does someone so small have so much rage inside of her?
Getting protective of her children is extremely hot.
You'd probably get targeted for harassment
if I did something like that.
I mean, shit, we're getting harassed.
We're fucking breathing in the mic.
Daileys get so post-it.
Nah, these aren't real strong, I take your words.
That would actually be fine.
We need art and all that sort of outfit.
A strong ghost hunting, which is punching us.
Someone said, hire a manager to screen marshmallows.
To spend money to get anonymous comments is pretty rough,
if I'm being honest.
Dr. King, thank you for the membership.
I appreciate it.
And then there's a few more.
I mean, you know the drill.
Clearly they've never seen a Chihuahua.
Oh, are you calling me a Chihuahua?
Because I'm we in region.
I would listen to the veiler through your mic.
I don't even see them.
I don't own the company.
Oh no, she's shadowboxing again.
Type of YouTube admin, not you though.
Small being read.
I'll cover that for a manager.
Man, I must get in my tributes.
I hate it here.
Just be spending money to protect the girl's mental health.
Well, so the upkeep of the company is like nothing next to nothing.
But if it's like, oh, we need to pay a whole other person to go through these marshmallows.
Like, I know it's very nice being able to give like anonymous comments and stuff and feedback on that.
And like, don't get rid of them for now.
But like, it's just another expense.
And the whole set up of the 820 split is like, the girls can do whatever extra they want with the money.
Because obviously the average agency is like 50 or less, I guess.
Not that kind of 50 or less.
I said the 50-50 or whatever.
You know what I mean?
They just transfer the cognate hazards to the person's people screen.
You can relax by using all your rage while you have fun.
Wonderful firecrackers, sirens.
The other has a very positive and tight-knit community, so far it's been good though.
You know, their mental fortune is better than we do.
Yeah.
It would lose a lot of charm, knowing that there's like a literally a third party.
Yeah, so that I would actually agree with that as well.
Like, imagine being like, oh, I've sent my tentacotta mummy.
And then it's like, it's some poor guy that we're paying.
We're paying has to like, rate your tentacle.
Like, this is high enough quality.
The man whimpered, here you go, Strani.
The reefling whimpered, here's the link.
Can you listen?
You can sit down, your mirrors are open.
Yes, yes, yes.
I just let things simmer first.
I mean, do you want VLR management for your pack or your little tentacle?
My morning voice, my woke up seven minutes before stream voice after the nap.
Yeah.
Or pay like, let me see if I can tap your ears a little.
Tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
Anywhere.
Um, here in the afternoon.
My tentacle is a Strani exclusive.
Sounds good.
So I managed to get mech assault work in, so we're definitely on for a mech assault stream.
Um, I'm taking a pause for a week on Elden Ring.
Um, and just because we have two insurance streams over in Scape, to try and bash out these wines.
But I'm getting nervous, I don't know if I can do it.
I freaking saw Narissa from Hollow Live is doing prayer.
And I think she's doing the altar as well with dragon bones and getting, and getting, uh, it's not Jailbirds for Narissa.
Wait, is it Jail? No.
Um, to like, run her dragon bones.
Oh mommy, I saw the new thumbnails there, correct? I want to use them as a desk, huh?
Yeah.
I'd admit it, the real reasons, the reasons can help finish the DLC for you.
All right, mech assault one and two, my child.
They made a mech assault two.
I don't think they made a mech assault two.
Okay, well we approve comments together on YouTube.
RuneScape is, Strani is the RuneScape chance there.
Yeah, it's Jailbirds.
Ah, newest Jailbirds. That's right, I know my features.
I was a very brave girl yesterday on Twitter, and I applied myself for one of those trends,
where it's like, put your model, and we might do, it's by Frame and Ebay Shrimp,
and they're making Wim Tattoos, so I posted my full model view,
which a lot of people don't get to see.
It's on my Twitter, the link's in the description.
If you just check out my replies on Twitter, you'll see it,
because yeah, I do not show the full view of my, is this room dark enough?
Maybe the room is dark enough for me to get away with it, hold on.
Hi, I'm Strani, this is my room.
I don't show it often for reasons, but yeah, this is me.
How did I do that?
You're supposed, no, microphone.
Sorry.
The microphone's not supposed to go big.
But yeah, I don't normally show that, because, yeah.
That was a brave girl, and, oh, that was a brave girl,
and like, put myself under one of those posts,
because I'm like, oh, hi, I'm Strani, I'm a weirdo,
but thank you for the opportunity for the Wim Tattoos.
Wim Tattoos, it's just a Scottish flag, honestly, if they even knew that.
I'd be very surprised if they knew I was Scottish.
And then I sent a VTuber, a message, a DM request for an ASMR collab,
but I sent it to someone that doesn't follow me, but that has open DMs.
And they were like, oh, looking to make friends.
Oh, wait, I'm gonna do it.
They were looking to make friends, and I asked for an ASMR collab.
I'm a fucking twat.
She was asking to make pals, no fucking compatriots.
Wim Tattoos that says, no got a fucking clue what that means.
It's a microphone now.
I thought you were going to intentionally have them make cover of the area.
Ooh, I'm happy, I knew I was such a brave girl.
But yes, we have a member's script writing stream.
I'll see how it gets received.
If it gets received well, that'll help out a lot.
I'm not even pretending, that'll help out so much.
I have you guys script writing streams, because it looks so bad.
But I made so much progress yesterday, and then I get to do the next seven group collabs.
That may or may not be on a certain feature-proof ASMR account.
Peaches, it's peaches, I can't show up, it's peaches, I peaches.
I mean, you can make friends over ASMR.
I know that whenever I do a message for ASMR, I'm always super up front, and I'm just like,
Hi, I'll make the collab, and I'll write it, and I'll edit it, and everything else that we don't buy me.
I'm a professional relationship type thing.
Don't forget about the stream delay during member's stream?
Yeah, you guys can tell me what you want me to put.
I'll do the b-paul thing, if you want to.
Me, I see a certain sense.
Wait, the seven man collab line up?
Hold on, let me type in the name.
Oh, my stomach is-
It's up, it's breaking up, okay.
The girl's seven man collab is all those boo-boo-boo-boo.
If you want to hear seven ASMR girls together, you can open that up and then pause on the side if you want.
And leave it a like when you listen to it and stuff.
Okay, so that's the second of four seven man ASMR collabs.
The next one is peaches.
As in dream of peaches, yeah.
But you can open that up.
Yes, demon in me.
I think the girls might make a solo ASMR roleplay with the look or something.
Because the art came out pretty good.
Unfortunately, Jaffa Redwood's colour blind and he keeps fucking me up.
You can listen to that later, alligator.
Make sure to like and subscribe.
Yeah, if you like ASMR, you can subscribe to me by the way.
I have lots of ASMR coming.
Okay, I'm going to approve of comments on YouTube.
I will read them out to you.
Four minutes ago, someone commented H on my short.
That just came out, so I'll approve that.
Someone posted on the Mamusa collab a sleeping emoji.
We will approve.
Someone on my debut, but posted double of hearts.
Feels good man.
I have a treat for you all this Saturday.
I hope you're ready for Saturday.
There's a treat on everyone's channel on Saturday.
So look out for that.
It will be on everyone's channel and it will come out like 10 minutes apart.
So you have to watch as they get released totally.
That's how it works, right?
What is approving comments?
So when you comment on my channel, it disappears, but it doesn't really.
It shows up in my little approval section and I get to read all the comments and approve them.
So I quite literally read every single comment.
Someone says, Microsoft, that brings back memories on my schedule.
Someone's saluted the clapping without hands.
It's a more video because it got deleted.
Someone said, power claps are over 9000.
Someone says, you know you have a giant cake when you make this kind of noises down.
That broke the sudden barrier.
I got you and enjoyed it.
Oh my lord, the cake is not a lie.
Nope, we aren't doing portal out here.
It's all in the thighs safely.
And then someone said rip to the actual original clapping video.
Am I working on more?
I'm like, yes.
So I see an Emmy haven't been approved and they're being made.
I've sent away Shibi's request.
I need to get Azura to tell me what batch attend she wants and then I need to use my brain power.
If someone can tweet me what my emotes were in batch 2, that'd be great.
I don't have access to Marshmallow because someone did it on Marshmallow.
Let's see.
Why does listening to your talk make my head spin?
Is it because I'm Scottish?
Is it because it's weird here?
Words said a bit differently.
I'm excited for Among Us with Yume Plus.
Oh, you're gonna hear the wrath of the Scots real quick and that's true.
That's where one of them accuses me of being it when I'm not it.
When someone accuses me of being it when I'm not it, I'm like absolutely screaming region.
Me when I'm it but accusing someone else of it.
I've got my latex gloves on.
Can you tell I've got a latex glove on?
Yeah.
What's the tentacle on the wall for anyway?
It's totally decorational.
We're not wearing functional hair again.
Okay.
Today is Patra's day so you have three streams today
and you're already listening to one of them right now.
Good to me.
I promise I'm a certified nurse.
I'm just checking out your ears to make sure you've got good tail in your ears.
And what about this ear?
This ear clearly is deficient in tingles.
I know what I can do in order to fix this.
I will administer five cc's of tingles to hold your breath mister.
I'll save you.
Okay.
Wow.
What are you gonna do with them glues?
Nurse Ronnie's will the tingles result in a main break?
Yeah?
Yeah, main break.
Today's more script stream goes well.
Maybe we can write a main break together
and I'll show you our hypnosis stuff.
Okay, let me inspect your ear again for any tingles.
Wow.
Okay, you tingled a little bit.
Can you feel my breath on your ear?
We need to administer even more tingles.
What can we do?
I'm looking.
Why?
I can clean them.
I'd like me to pick up my handy-dandy tool
because you need to tingle or else you're gonna perish for some reason.
In the world's 26th day, if you do not tingle once a day, you fall into a coma.
Surely she wouldn't make the break.
If you were a nurse, I would always want to be sick.
Any chance the girls will play a game together?
Yes, we actually posted it in the discord.
So, quite possibly.
Okay.
I think you're tingling a little, so I'm returning to normal in this ear,
which is good news.
Very, very good news.
Yes.
Wow, wow, wow.
There we go.
Slow and steady went to tingle it.
Breathing a little.
Please make me gentle.
I have no idea how this among us collapse is gonna go.
I was like, so when, if you didn't know, I'm gonna teach you.
Okay?
I'm gonna teach you the insider knowledge, which is when you do group collabs or collabs of that nature,
you show up one hour before this stream time to sort out any connection problems of a discord DM.
Always makes me nervous.
I'm like, oh god, the girls okay?
Okay, the girls are not dying.
This is fantastic news.
I love it when the girls aren't dying.
It's my favorite thing.
I was getting so nervous.
I'm like, why have I been ahead?
Every day I come.
Oh, sorry.
I should have finished that sentence there.
Every day I come home and get stuck locked by VLR ASMR streams.
Yeah.
Bro, can I say that every collab is so unlucky?
It's like every...
Bro, I am still so mad at the pepper washer devs.
Not only do they lock free play mode multiplayer behind the campaign,
we can't even connect each other.
Am I made it safely?
Is she in the Bahamas or some shit?
I don't even know where she is.
She just put on the team-up schedule.
I'm away and I'm like, as long as you're safe,
that's all that's important to me as long as you have fun.
I actually don't know where she's looking like.
Amy's in heaven otherwise.
It's like I can still hear her.
What do you mean?
I'm right here, big brother.
Amy, are you not supposed to be on holiday?
Oh, yeah, sometimes.
Amy, go be on holiday and relax.
My main place would be...
Sometimes I can still hear her voice.
Amy, Amy, are you there?
Yeah.
Oh, who the fuck?
I'm communicating with her right now telepathically.
Amy, what do you want to say to the pentpals?
Thank you for denying me.
Amy, Amy, you can't say that out loud.
That's the quiet part out loud.
Maybe it's Jill.
Amy, I'm sure.
It's like she never left.
Amy, is that you?
Is it so cold out here?
Ah, fuck it, why not?
Right, Amy, what kind of tingle do you want to do?
I don't have a fucking clue.
Alright, Amy, that doesn't help this collab.
Fuck it, we'll do something, alright?
Have a boo, you kiss the pentpals.
You know?
Well, that collab went well, don't you think?
That was the quickest and easiest collab in my life.
Now I can clickbait this stream with Amy's shoulder on it real quick.
There's just Amy and the Beast.
There's just Amy and the Beast in the room with us.
Strongly, the accident was a year ago.
You have to let Amy go.
No, not my little sister.
I've pressed down on your ears a little bit.
I've pressed on your ears a little bit, okay?
Amy, see me?
Went into a power washer.
I think power washer would have to be a four-man collab.
As soon as we got more than four people in the game,
the game was like no avana.
No one can collab with me at this time, ever.
I'll do it myself.
I say, I say, come in for a minute.
No, what do you want?
Strongly, I'm tired.
I just finished streaming.
I see, I see, do you want to hear it again?
I'm going to do some more ASMR.
But Strongly, my voice is broken.
I can't.
Right, well, I tried.
I tried Snow Berries, but AC can't make it.
Strongly, you just went near all of these.
That's it, I'll get Azura, and hold on.
Azura?
They're one, yeah.
To do more ASMR with me.
I look good when I'm pressing Azura, it's just a moment.
Oh wait, no, I said no.
Oh no.
Wait a minute, how am I typing in chat right now?
This isn't possible.
You're teasing us, are you?
What the fuck are you typing in chat?
I don't stream at the same time.
AC, how are you?
Do you got your phone out?
No.
Someone's pretending to be me on stream.
The whole ASMR is stopped here, and there's already so much of it.
AC is feeding the masses with ASMR.
Literally, my impression of Azura is just...
I can't.
My sweet, bleeding heart.
That's a bit of it, I know.
Strongly is joystick there too.
Yeah, they're long with one little bit of it.
As well as Karambit.
And Strongly365.
Oh, the terrible one.
Hold on, I'll chat to the latex.
Azura's too mummy for you.
Would you mean my deadpan accent?
Can you do our mouth voice?
Would you, I mean, no.
I just don't stream, what's going on?
I'm pretending to be all...
No, sorry, I'm proving that I'm all avirable right now.
Amy was on stream earlier, you just missed it by a ball here.
Actually, she's just gone away on holiday,
she's just jumped on the plane, but she was in my room as I had to go.
Oh, it's Stacy Milka, and how can you forget?
Wait, we'll see if I can get Amy again,
even though she's on a plane right now.
Amy.
What the fuck is Amy's voice again?
Hold on.
Big brother.
It's actually just called V strongy, this company's a veil.
It's not real.
Strongy can't hurt you.
Strongy with her 18 billion personas.
Azura's natural rasp is hard to nail.
Oh yeah, do you want me to fuck it?
I'm gonna go put on Azura right now.
Azura de ule de lu e.
Okay, so I've typed in Azura de lu e, so over for you fuckers.
Let's see, live.
Ah, Azura de ule de lu e.
That's a new short out, let's go.
Right, let's see what her ASMR was.
Don't be afraid to talk in this video, Azura.
Okay, Azura actually doesn't talk much in her fucking reals,
it's just a stray then.
So I can mimic her voice.
Azura shy, geez.
I'm gonna have to spank her.
Hey Azura, you need to start talking in your streams more
so I can mimic you during an ASMR section of mine.
Thanks, that'd be great.
You know what, I'm gonna put our trailer on,
because I know for a fact she speaks in her trailer.
Get route, videos.
Trailer, let's go.
I hope you still have room in your heart
for a coach goddess like me.
For I am Azura de ule,
and I hope you can join me soon
on some tantalizing discussions together.
I'm just drew a copy in her trailer.
I played it, I don't know, I mean,
I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
I played it, I don't know.
Yeah, I know, I'm muted to death though.
Her late is short, should I give her her late is short ago?
Someone told me
my voice is so soothing
that I could read out a dictionary.
So we're going to try today.
Says Veeler here.
I'm all of Veeler.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, that's good.
What was that actually?
Are you guys just hyping me up?
Wait, are you guys being serious?
Are you hyping me up or can I actually mimic Azura as well?
No Veeler, it's just, she is veeler.
Holy goat, you're actually pretty good looking impressions.
Oh, wait until you do that.
I'm going to hear Marcia's lovely impression.
I'm going to shit you up with her.
It's funny, Azura sounds like someone else.
No, you're supposed to say I sounded like her.
Right today,
and that means
to make something better.
You actually sounded like her.
Hype me up, hype me up, give me more delusions,
give me more personas.
Veeler will decide your fate.
I am Veeler.
Boy, better than expected.
Now try Mercy Modest.
Sorry, I'll try Mercy Modest.
Mercy Modest.
I think Marcia's the only accent that doesn't compliment me.
Which is terrible.
Right, let's listen to a short from Marcia.
Okay.
Sorry, don't send that easily.
Don't worry.
Oh, but she's like, I'm trying on solar.
What's her trailer?
Debut and turn first?
What better story than that of a modest young student?
No, she's not like that.
Turn violent and dairy overnight.
Mercy's pretty unique, that's hard.
I didn't always look...
I've not gone up.
Mercy's too really difficult.
Mercy's really difficult.
She...
I can do Mercy's laugh like that.
Sorry, that was really loud.
So now you already have a mommy voice when you talk to yourself.
Someone was like, you're disappointed.
Mommy voice like, shit me up in your fucking...
On your...
Elden Ring stream.
They were like, scared of how disappointed I sounded.
Can we hear your best straw necks?
Fuckin' thing.
I'm Scottish.
Mercy's too yandere in my mic, unless you're also yandere.
Do your catchphrase.
I'm Mercy Modest, and on my ass you will feast.
That's not my kohei, just a manic laughter.
Gosh, Scottish girls make me melt.
Actually, too, will be.
Try Shavey.
Right, let's...
Oh, I need a fart.
Attuded.
I just want to report for any bread breakers.
I'm technically on day five.
Give up for day five of having constipation.
Right, Shavey.
Shavey, get out of there, out in the open.
Okay, let's listen to her debut.
Oh fuck, she's deep voiced as well.
Like, I knew that about...
Oh, hold on.
I'm Shavey Cottonbum, the madam of the sister...
Ah, fuck, I don't have that.
I hope I can take off a lot of boxes for you.
Such as ropes, milk, bunny.
Yeah, I know, I get that.
No shit dune challenge.
Starting at some point, it's gonna need to be scooped out.
Do you know why it's called the scooping room?
It's because you scoop shit in it, you dumbass.
Sister location for Netflix hilarious.
And I won't have any other...
...literations.
Get to day nine and you can pretend it's just straight up gender.
Bro, my stomach is so big right now.
Yeah, you need to really deep for Shavey.
You do a good mouth voice.
You want a Scottish mouth? How do I do a Scottish mouth?
Well, I know how to do a Scottish mum.
Away and fucking clean your room.
That's a Scottish mum, but not a Scottish mouth.
Oh, darling, have you been naughty?
Or do you need to clean your room?
Or are you needing a mouth like me to come in and help you?
I can do lots for you.
Pinned over the bed and pick up all the stuff that's on the rack.
For half a year some more, man.
Yeah, what do we do?
Join the animatronic family.
We open the rail soon.
Your tummy's big, sorry, my bad.
A circus baby.
Do you know why?
It's called the scooping room.
I just love the way she says it.
It's like, you fucking idiot.
Well, I wasn't ready for the mummy video.
I need to renew my passport.
Why do you need to renew your passport?
What triggered in your head to need to renew your passport in this monster?
How many days will you get before the doctor?
Oh, I just need to give my...
Not to be nasty.
But if you ever have trouble with your back door,
just get a little enema kit.
Enema, enema, give them an enema.
I'm really stuck.
Because if you like playing in the back door,
that's what you do.
Sorry, your mouth voice is too powerful.
That's hostile.
It's just the facts.
Sorry, you're getting educated against your will.
Okay.
Oh, the face tracking thinks the ace cube,
the ace globe is my face.
Hold on, it's missing up a little bit.
Circus baby, you had to ask the Scottish scooping room
because you had to have a thing scooping in it.
It's not that complicated.
Hey, Stroney, how's the stream don't...
Don't, just don't.
How's the stream don't...
Sorry.
Just don't do it, stop it.
24 hours fast though,
if you have a lot planned, learn that hard way.
No, you don't need to fast.
Minor spelling mistake.
Spotted everyone pointing that.
We're kidding, I'm teasing.
I think I might like the Scottish lady's voice,
because I'm Scots.
Minor spelling.
Teasing, I'm teasing.
My mouth is tracking to the ace globe.
You stop that.
Go to fuck, they sleep.
Oh, I'm doing a song cover.
I might be able to do it
and record the raw vocals after.
The Yumi plus, if I don't go too crazy.
Although basically whenever I finish streaming
for the day I go to bed now.
Because I got so much work done.
So much work done yesterday.
It's recommended to fast if you go spelunkin'.
Have a mesmerizing time, everyone.
Wish I could stay for the script writing stream,
but I'm sure the time is fantastic.
It will be the stream will remain up,
because we'll use substitutes like tentacle and ink.
And we're just talking about honey tea.
That's all.
I just need to make a little bit of honey tea.
We'll have my sleep on.
Angry Scots talks you in a bed.
See you, you're another one.
You never sleep at night, what's going on with you?
Like a frickin' insomnia.
Don't be up on that male twin and gummies
that all them Americans are on about all the faking time.
No, let me talk you in real nice and tidy
and get your act up so you can faking go to sleep.
Because I've had enough of you been awake all day.
Faking clean the whole house.
Clean the whole bloody house and what do I get in the town?
Faking you coming over.
Cuttin' faking toast on the bunker.
On the bunker, as if there's any plates available.
As if you can't just use a wee bit of kitchen roll.
Do you know what the worst thing that really annoys me?
That you do.
See the fuckin' butter?
When you make toast and then you use the knife
to spread the butter and then you put the knife back in the butter.
So now the butter has fuckin' toasty bread
comes all over it.
Like it actually does matter to me.
Anyway.
That's what Scottish Rage ASMR would sound like.
Ugh.
I'm frickin' struggling to find an artist as well.
To do all my crazy things.
I've still not ordered the pregnancy artwork.
And...
I want it to come out a really good way
but I don't have an artist to do it.
I want...
She's not acting anymore.
Strutting the record.
Twisted crumbs and butter are the worst.
I'm sorry about the butter.
She's not acting anymore.
You know I'm not acting because my dad's coming over
and that's exactly what he does.
My mum used to get on it all the time for it
and he used to be like,
oh but I'm making toast for my breakfast
before I go to work.
Like he didn't see the issue with having crumbly
butter.
Alert of the classic lure pack fam.
We love a bit of lure pack.
Pregnancy ASMR would be my best.
I know mum can cook literally tummy-sits
and I'm saying how proud I am of you
and I can't wait to see
everything you accomplish in the world
and how you navigate that
and how big and strong you're gonna be
and I'm gonna look forward to
the sleepless nights that you keep me awake
after you're born because
I know you're not always gonna be in the newborn stage
before I know it you'll be walking
you'll be babbling
you'll start having your own personality
and interest and it's gonna be so cute.
And then I'm gonna get all emotional
because I'll be like one day I'll hold you
and then I'll never hold you again
because you're all big and grown up
my little weifling, no.
But yes, I need to find an artist
that's willing to draw something like that.
If not I might have to go to Fiverr
but Fiverr is always such a gamble
and I don't want to gamble on the artwork
because it means so much.
To make it.
The one where we're the father and the child?
Yes.
I'm not supposed to cry.
Stop it.
No, don't cry.
It's supposed to be like a fun goofy day or something.
But yeah, if I get a good sleep
after the Yumi Plus collab
then I have a feeling
that the next 2000 days
some more collab's gonna be up.
There's no one available on Skib.
I have never used Skib
because apparently you can't even talk
to the person in the commission
and I'm like,
if I'm paying for something
and I'm not allowed any corrections
unless I'm paying like a literally
cheapest chips for it
I'm too scared to use Skib.
Like, per Emi
she wanted some artwork Skib
or something we're planning while she's away
and then she was like,
oh fuck it, I'll just draw it myself
because she was like,
it's gonna get too much of a headache
it's really unreliable
because she,
I think she's used it before
and it's unreliable or something.
There's also Vegen.
I fucking hate Vegen.
It's alright but I also hate it at the same time.
I really wanna take responsibility right now
what, forget me pregnant
and being in my tummy at the same time?
It's the reason that Skib's actually really cheap.
Oh, maybe,
maybe I should look at Skib.
I'd like to get the girls like artworks
just like here and there like,
I don't know if you saw,
I got Mercy this artwork.
It was just a doodle artwork
so it's quite cheap overall.
And it was her and Serenity together.
Why do you hate Vegen?
Because I thought so, since they were all,
whenever I commissioned someone on Vegen,
I fucking messaged them on Twitter
and asked for the commission
because it's such a fucking nightmare.
Trying to like send the request off.
I'd rather message on Twitter and be like,
are you gonna accept this request?
If yes, like please let me know
and I'll say like, here's my username
on Skib, on Vegen.
Because I kind of be arse filling out
the fucking, fucking mile long essay
just for them to reject it.
I get why it's set up like that
but I'm like, go and get to fuck honestly.
We just got here,
what are you people talking about?
We're talking about making an artist request
because I don't really have an artist
that I want to draw me pregnant with a refling.
There's no other way to say it.
I need to be drawn pregnant with a refling.
I'll always take responsibility
with a refling.
Why do you know all of my buttons?
I absolutely hate those.
It's terrible right now.
I'm cleaning your ear again.
Ah, because all the steps
I was thinking of trying to draw in Vegen.
This is good.
I think if you're a creator on it
it's very good.
Although there's been a lot of feedback
about how it's like next time
possible to get a refund.
So yeah, oh my voice just cracked.
All of the artists I've worked with
ended up adding me on Twitter
or Discord, it's just so much easier.
Honestly, the guy that made all our banners
he's called Waltz with me
I'm like, would he be crazy enough
to draw me pregnant with a refling?
I think he might.
If I give him a reference.
I think I might ask Waltz with me
to do the pregnant one.
I'm trying to be given that hot-tooth.
Why doesn't Jaferero want to draw pregnant with me?
I've been...
Jaferero has been
drawing me a bit manly
the last few commissions
and they came to keep having to correct
and be like, please stop drawing me
as a man.
Please stop drawing me if I was on Twitter.
And it's kind of got to the point where it's like...
Yeah.
So I'm kind of looking to spread my artist wings
at the moment.
Try giving a reference.
Mysteries called Fish Peppers, I guess.
Yeah.
Waltz is good to work with.
What?
No, Jaferero would do...
Oh no, he's like there for anything else.
And he's like, what do you want?
And I'm like this and he's like
okay, I guess.
But yeah, recently
I've been getting drawn as a man
like a big thick neck, a big massive chin
and I'm like
kind of corrected a few times
and it's
it's not really
being changing.
And I'm just like
yeah.
So yeah.
I'm going to try and spread my artist wings
a little bit.
Then
I'm sure there'll be a few more things
from Jaferero Pop.
They can all be winners, you know.
The style changed a bit.
Yeah, no, artist style changed all the time.
Which is not a problem
but
something that changes
outside of like
a barrel chest and huge arms
the princess carry.
I'm not sure
how many more to draw.
Yeah.
So I'll see if
Waltz, I think Waltz is
Japanese.
I don't know if you guys
know this but the Japanese
yen is crashing.
Like
absolutely crashing at the minute.
Maybe I should do skips
but
yeah, it's like completely crashing
at the minute.
So maybe yeah, skips would be
way cheaper than usual but I've never used the
website before.
I hate
having to learn how to use
new websites.
But
I'm playing with the
ball crusher.
Wait, the yen's crashing?
Yeah, like I think against the dollar
the yen just continues to go down.
Like it's something weird.
I don't know why.
It's a really good time to buy Japanese stuff.
Wow.
Good time to visit as well.
Up in
the Sakura Park
I feel like we'd be so disruptive though.
We need to be quiet. We need to whisper.
It's been down since Covid but it's currently
at as low as it's like 50 cent time.
The dollar.
The what crusher?
The ball crusher.
I have this like sensory toy
and I squish it and stuff
and it feels really nice to squish.
So it is being dubbed to the
ball crusher.
Japan economy
nothing great. I wonder if the birth rate
of Japan is? I assume it's down as well.
Is there any first world
country that doesn't
have
a declining birth rate?
I want to say no. Maybe?
No. America.
America as opposed to birth rate?
Maybe.
I'm not sure.
Anything above one is good.
It is insufficient.
Time to leave to Japan and we'll be right to there.
Will we all go to Japan?
I don't know. Can you farm?
Yeah, you can farm in Japan.
But I don't think they have castellos the way
Scotland has castellos.
Can you
choose a nicer name
than why I'm making you nervous?
Streamer has too much fun
playing with the ball crusher.
ASMR.
America is on the down
as well.
I can take care of that declining birth rate.
I remember there was a post
where it was like, I don't know if it was just
an onion headline. Probably was, let's be
honest. Of course that would fall for an onion
headline. It was like Japan's
declining birth rate
makes visas
for foreigners easier
and then someone was like, step aside.
This is a job for me.
I'll fix the birth rate.
But that's the thing about
being a sperm donor. If you didn't
know, you're actually not allowed to
have more, you're not
allowed to have more than
children, but someone
recently, well not recently,
it made the news like a year or so ago
in America, he'd use
different names at sperm banks, so he would have
like a massive lineage
and he got caught doing it. I don't know
if he got jail time for it, because you're not
supposed to pollute the pool like that
or else it would be like a Genghis Khan moment.
Everyone's like, huh, how strange.
We're all seem to be related to Genghis Khan, I wonder why.
And it was like, my guy, have you
even hair to half the stuff that man did?
Sorry, you clean
your ears after all the filth I just
spoke there, hold on.
Okay, there we go.
Much better.
Can't be speaking about
that stuff right now, that's what we're
revealing.
That one guy
that snuck around
dozens of places, yeah,
so you didn't know about it.
Japanese birth rate
is so low that the previous prime minister
became a meme
for trying to boost the
you would think
immigration would be easier to the birth rate.
I heard that Japan's racism
is pretty strong.
It's just
quite funny
since it's like, that kind of seems
like the solution.
America's birth rate is only
because of immigration.
One of our states, Alabama,
has had its first statewide population
decline in the sense of
speak more filth.
We enjoy it.
There's a reason his lineage
spread far and wide.
Exactly.
In a real article, Japan
released a dating app
for people who are looking for
committed relationships to get married
and have children.
So like, the opposite
of any other
Western countries
dating apps.
Imagine hundreds of years later
and there are historians wondering
who this singular man
who has a 20-way pattern formed
or Japan is almost
allergic to immigration.
I used to watch lots of videos
from Japanese YouTubers.
There's this girl called Shaila
in Japan, or Shadamander.
It's kind of like her nickname.
And she talks about Japan a lot.
She talks about running
a bed and breakfast series, which is
really cute. She renovated a house
into like a Neko
bed and breakfast and they were so
cute.
I find it quite sweet
and adorable.
Japan started using China to
increase the birth rate. That's sad.
Eh?
You mean modern day?
Or do you mean
the history we do not speak of?
Shinzo Abe
is no longer asking.
That reminds me, I made a meme for
Emi of that. I don't think she's ever posted it.
Before I met
the girls, I made like a few memes for them
each to post on Twitter if they wanted to
because I was like, I have no idea what they want to do
on Twitter. And one of the tweets
is a, one of the
meme pictures is Emi holding a gun
and she's like, I'm no longer asking her
things.
Japan has multiple dating apps for gamers
and mates that are all owned and run by the
government.
It's giving
date or you shouldn't have your hand
over it.
A declining birth rate is a good thing.
Our planet can't sustain all of us.
I, I thought
our planet could sustain us is because
of what we do to it. Like, we can't
sustain. Not that we want
infinite growth of humans, but
like,
I thought
someone
draws vtuber's prego.
Are they cheap for this?
Are they gonna draw me holding my belly
all happy
in smiling and then a little
rifling attached to me in like a
little insane shot with a rifling
in the umbilical
card?
Are they gonna do it?
You made memes for them?
memes for them. I made memes, I wrote their ASMR scripts, I wrote some of the shorts.
I think Amy's the only one that has shorts up that I didn't write like her story about
that haunted house and she got grabbed in the middle of her sleep as she slipped next
to her mum. She did some stuff that I didn't make. But everything else the girls have done
I made. And they're all kind of waiting on me, but I'm going to spank them and be like
ok, your debut period is over now, you need to start thinking about doing stuff for yourself
because I can't be doing it for everyone. But yes, I tried to set them up as best I
can and it certainly worked out. If we've all hit 5000 subscribers in our first month
that's fantastic. Pregnancy is kind of so wholesome, I don't know why it has a stigma.
Probably because the child is a parasite on the woman. Did you know that the reason why
women forget that childbirth is so painful is because that's an evolutionary trait to
trick you into wanting more children. Even though it's the most traumatic experience
and most dangerous thing you will ever go through in your entire life as a woman.
Eee-dee! Science Facts with Stormy. Would you like more science facts about pregnancy?
The child, the body diverts as much nutrition to the child first or parasite as I like to
call it. Which leaves some mothers who lose their teeth, lose their hair, lose some of
their sight. Yeah, it's pretty rough if you want to be pregnant out here.
Teach them how to fish. Biology 101. Yes, pregnancy is absolutely terrifying. If you
actually know what goes on behind, how easy it is to hemorrhage, die in childbirth. Even
C-sections, how it leaves you with a lifelong inability. Pregnancy also damages your bladder,
it also damages your back passage during the birth. You can quite literally create one
singular rip in between the panini and the baby. So yeah, don't, don't recommend pregnancy.
Congrats if you want to go through it. It will turn your nips brown. That's the only thing.
So if you're used to them being pink, don't be surprised. They change color. Life is just
suffrax and honestly, do not be a whammin' and do not get pregnant is my advice. I was
in the room when my youngest bro was being birthed. It's a horror for, oh, it is not
for the faint of heart. It is not. And like, if we're not memin' for a second, you know
how the meme's like, oh, would you rather get punched in the balls or birth a child?
And then like, oh, I'm a C-section baby. You're removed like a chipper. That's a fact
why I've never heard before. Oh, it's so dangerous. It's unbelievably dangerous. Wait,
what did I just come into? I'm currently ranting about how dangerous pregnancy is whilst trying
to harass an artist to draw me pregnant with you. So you're gonna be in my tummy and I'm
gonna make a weird ASMR where you hear my tummy sounds and I'm talking to you and saying
how much I love you and I can't wait till you should come out and achieve all these things.
My nips are already brown. Well, then you make me a different race than me, then. Unfortunately,
I'm as pale as they come. My nips practically blend in, honestly. Sorry, this isn't an ASMR.
I'm just fucking ranting about pregnancy. I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Did you guys get DM'd
by that feature that wants you to draw a pregnant tooth? Trying to get around Vore, but still
want to use the sense that it's pregnant, eh? There's a reason diet and childbirth is a
common trope. It is. You can also get a thing called coffin birth. If a mother who is, her
ego is pregnant when she passes away and so does the child, the buildup of guesses actually
expelled the child on that has been dubbed coffin birth. Just thought you should know.
Not very nice. Aye. What's that? I'm just like an endless source of repeating things I've
heard or learned. Sheesh. Okay, let me actually do this. I'm sorry for freaking you about
the facts about me being pregnant after you made me pregnant. Refling, okay? I'll stop
scaring you. Thank you for being brave, your mommy's bravest soldier.
ASMR. Let's learn each front name and I'm not ASMR, because let's be honest. Wow.
ASMR.
Where's the Vore ASMR?
I wanted to do giant test 4 with a zero. I didn't write the script yet. Well, I
don't think I'll be writing the script the whole of this, right?
I could definitely do a siren. Vore's you. Giant siren, because I'm a siren. But I'm
actually a cowfish. See, I'm a siren that can't sing, so I had to use something else.
And then I went for hypnotic abilities, so then I became a cowfish. I don't know.
Don't ask about the lore. I didn't, I didn't come up with it.
Is this what miski was here 24-7?
Creasy, I think I just found out what coffin birth was today. Get educated, get educated, get educated.
ASMR.
Millen right now forever. I would prefer wholesome siren to bad ending siren.
Where I just fucking hypnose you and tear a mouth and then keeps you in your stomach so you can't sleep.
All your bases are belong to us. Okay, you ready? I'm gonna, I'm gonna swallow you right now.
And then this says you're going down into my tummy, okay?
You're in my tummy now. Do you hear my tummy?
There's my tummy. It's making lots of noises.
So basically, that's what the pregnancy ASMR is going to sound like, but I'm just complimenting you on that side.
Oh, this is what it sounds like when I'm pregnant and you're safe in my tummy too.
Oh, my little reef egg.
Hot dog. This place is magnificent.
Okay, well, let's spit you back out of my tummy now.
I shouldn't have swallowed you. Okay, I'll bring you back up.
I'll bring you back up my tummy, but first, first what?
You get to listen to my heart, so I'm gonna do so.
How much is the rent in here?
Now, let's spit you out. You're already coming back up. You're back up in my heart now.
I'm about to spit you out of my mouth.
I don't want to go out the other way, exactly. Either I spit you out of my mouth,
or you come out the other way. Your choice. And I'm already on day five of being backed up,
so you'll be sitting for a while.
Wait, it's all cold. I don't even have any cold.
Okay, I think I'm ready to spit you out.
I'm replaying. There you go. See, it didn't swallow you for long.
That just reminded me. I need to order artwork of me eating you like a Calamari
squid that's still alive. You know those Japanese fucked up mukbangs?
Oh, wait, no, is it South Korean? I think it's South Korean. Or is it Chinese?
Shit. I think one of them was a South Korean girl, and she was eating stuff alive.
I just remembered I have to order an artwork like that as well.
Oops, because I'm going to bore you alive.
I've been on a mean way. I'm not going to chew, so I don't hurt you, okay?
Oh, you don't want to be back out here? You want to be back on my tummy again?
Oh, you should be.
That was a fun read. Did you enjoy it? You're all slimy now, though. Hold on.
I think I need to... I'm going to wait for you down, okay?
Because you're all covered in musk, but I just need to...
Did you hear my tummy? My tummy's asking for you to go back and say you're very king, but right now...
What am I listening to? I just swallowed you, and then I just un-swallowed you.
But now I'm cleaning the spit off of your ears.
I'm sorry if you're used to AC's really cute ASMR.
Here, we get a little freaky around these poles.
AC, how about you tell them?
Okay, so Strani's really fucking weird.
I don't know why, but she just tries to make everyone happy,
but it comes out with really inappropriate stuff.
Thanks, AC, for that recap. I'll do it.
You're welcome.
Yeah, I do come out, actually. Thank you, AC.
What?
I need to get more of the spit off of your insomnia. There's so much spit.
Okay, I think you're dry. Oh, that's pretty good. My wife is here.
That's good enough to do it for her.
I don't know, kind of. Actually, I get to find out in my RuneScape stream what kind of stuff the
girls have been up to because I get to watch the girls. For Azura's one, I'm going to watch her
monetization stream. I'm going to see if there's like two hours each girl has done,
because if I watch two of her streams from each girl, that's 10 hours of RuneScape wings.
And then I get to do a commentary on the girls.
Yeah, I gave you a little species too. Just a test. Sorry if you hear me tell me.
Just a test that it's a little dry. Yeah, you're dry.
Okay, wow.
When is Elden Ring the lore video watcher? There's lore videos on Elden Ring, aren't they?
I love that you've collabed with Yunya. Well, it was probably a given, to be honest. It was
probably a given. All things considered.
Shibi is coming online in 20 minutes, right? Oh no, it's going to be on my tummy.
Please tell me you're running the ASMR. You're running the experience.
Did we finish the Elden Ring DLC? No, we're taking a break on it, because
I've fucked my health up, so I can't do any more endurance for a few days.
She says, as she has, what's coming up? I've got mechisol, which is apparently eight hours,
but I don't believe it. And then I have membership ASMR, which is one tingle equals one clap.
I thought that was quite creative myself. So you guys tell me whenever you tingle in the stream,
and then I clap. In that way. There is a Mama Yunya collab. Yeah, you're allowed to watch it
after I finish streaming, but if I redirect into Shibi, then you have to watch Shibi.
Balthro, I don't know how long we're gonna go for, but I'm definitely gonna need to start being
a bit kinder to myself with the endurance streams until my health gets back, because I've been
very silly. I'm not looking after myself. She says that she does three streams in a day, but
it's not hard to do three streams because it's two hours at ASMR, which I'm literally just about to
finish off. And then we're gonna write a script. I'm gonna go offline, make a cup of tea, get a
cola, and then we're gonna write a script together, and then I'll gauge if you guys enjoyed it. Like,
I'll do a poll at the end of the stream, and either you say you enjoyed it or you didn't enjoy it.
And then I take a break, and then I put up with you, me plus, and I hope you're ready for the
scrunch break. It's only seven days while we talk about your period here. You aren't gonna
last clapping that much. I can do it by default. I don't have to do anything special to clap.
Like, do I need to- did you not see the new short? Hold on, I'm gonna link a short in chat.
Okay, I'm gonna link a short in chat. It is 20 seconds long. You are welcome to watch it right now.
Okay. You may watch this short. I give you permission to watch it.
I'll wait 20 seconds. I'll just do blooping ASMR for 20 seconds whilst you watch that short
that I've linked in chat.
Wait, no VLR members streaming? Oh, no, it's gonna be. Oh, shit. Oh, yeah. Wait a minute,
I forgot. People don't normally stream multiple times, and there's a lot.
Once you're healthy again, keep looking after yourself. Challenge impossible. I want to play
Elden Ring. I want to get carried. Carry me, carry me, carry me, plop, plop, plop.
I could totally make that audio.
Oh, I'm so tempted to make a Twitter audio now that I've said that out loud.
Oh, I'm so tempted.
I'm so tempted to literally, plop, plop, plop, and say get carried, carry me, carry me,
until fireworks. Oh, I shouldn't have said that because I don't want to do it.
No hands clapping is a talent for sure. So now do you believe that in the membership ASMR
I can clap? Every time someone says I tingled when I do something, I tingle you, then yeah.
Please carry me audio. Yeah, literally. Please make that Twitter audio. I just might.
I just got what she meant by holding her jibblies. Yeah, my boobah. I need to hold them in place
because when I jump up and down, they jump with me. Surprise. We all are just one person.
Yes, please do it. Do it. You want no boss? No boss. That's how you say it in Scotland.
If you either say the plate way, which is a double donut to your year, or you say
shake bag if you didn't, or you say date new boss.
What if the plopping gives tingles, infinite tingles? No, I have to actually do something.
You can't just be like, I tingled because like I moved across the room.
No, it doesn't work like that.
My stomach is making some cringey. You have a very particular skill set, yeah.
I mean, I could do it right now if you want.
So this is a sample of what's going to be happening in the members ASMR. Hold on, let me just,
I'm not sure if I'm going to hear it if I don't know.
Infinite tingle exploit. It's a video game. Oh, should I make a video game, but it's all
about clapping? Okay, hold on, I need to do it. My headset, I was actually hearing what the heck is
going on. I don't know if I'm jumping to the left though because I have to like pretty much
the jump to the left. That one's on the house. Okay, I'm completely in the chair again.
How high can I jump? Not very. I don't have much of a vertical leap.
Let me put this back on.
What the heck?
I have a wet patch, what's it called?
She doesn't know, maybe if I had to move her in a video game, one would be like inking,
two would be clapping, three would be banshee screaming, and four would be
tea something. The tick damage on this glass. Okay, there's that back down again.
Sorry, add that, add that, go back on, it's quite cold.
That's a great talent man, I can do it.
I think we've just discovered a terrible oversight by myself. I don't think I can
redirect into a viewer member. Community, community? No, unity in shambles right now.
Analytics, no not analytics. Redirect, is there anyone who can redirect online?
There's no one at UMI Plus online either. That's it, VNU, I'm looking at you next.
Oh wait, Mero, Mero might be coming online. We Mero, listening to this while studying,
me studying hard, Tescare, small, grabbable.
What did you call me, a grabbable cuttlefish? I don't think I've ever been called a grabbable
cuttlefish, that's amazing. A grabbable cuttlefish. Okay, Mero's not coming online until a couple of
hours. Thank you so much for the five fabry mathy, fabry mathy. Enjoy your studying,
sorry if I made it hard. Honestly, it's me, what's going to happen? The most vital thing I heard
about someone with the large butt, look at the arsonat, look at the arsonat thing, you know she
can shake, that's fucking mean. Oh my god, squeeze the cuttlefish, hold the cuttlefish,
get mesmerized by the cuttlefish, get mained broken by the cuttlefish.
Okay, now there better be someone online at VNU headquarters, I'm gonna scream,
I'm going to subscribe to literally everyone right now, so it tells me who the heck is online.
Okay, I'm gonna close, I'm gonna refresh my page, damn girl, you're shooting it.
Oh, there's not one VNU girl online right now, what's going on at VNU headquarters, please?
I can't fucking handle it right now, so we're doing fucking that 4v maria that can never
spell right, 4v, 4v maria. So you can literally hear all that click, I'm like desperately trying
to find someone to redirect into because I don't want to like, it's not like I'm gonna waste,
wait maybe Rem's doing that ASMR thing. Oh come on Rem, okay I'm gonna refresh the page again,
surely there's someone we can redirect into, surely some of the other streamers online that
doesn't hate us as an agency, oh for fuck's sake not one of them's online, this has to be a joke.
VNU and 4v maria didn't have one person online, that's not possible.
And of course mythos don't stream on YouTube because that would be too easy.
No way, no fucking way, was it mythos, HQ really don't stream on you on this,
not the body don't. Oh no they do, question mark, wait hold on,
pause the phone, why do I not think, why do I think they stream on Twitch?
Why did it, oh,
VR, can't you see, oh sorry if you're gonna fucking call yourself sort of abstract,
didn't you expect dumbasses like me to understand what on earth is going on,
Rem, oh Rem comes online in nine minutes, okay I'm gonna ASMR the fuck out of you.
Okay we're gonna redirect into Rem, redirect to a surrounding couple, she's streaming right now I
think, literally, right, when I redirect into Rem, my little pumpkins please, don't be,
don't, don't, I'm comfortable with you because I love you, I don't know what other VTubers
comfortability levels are, like you know how we're complete djans out here, we're just saying,
we're allowed to be, but just, wait Rem isn't too, I don't say that,
no he's, Rem isn't, Rem isn't coming up, wait, what,
whoever that wiefling says that Rem is coming online in nine minutes,
no, no she's not, destroy that man,
doesn't Merrow stream in seven minutes, no Merrow doesn't, like you mean Merrow,
Merrow, it says Merrow's coming online at 12 p.m.
No, is it, can I read, is there anyone,
you could read strongly, she's live in seven, she is live in seven minutes on a member stream,
can't, can't redirect to our members, is there not one person, there has to be one
fucking streamer up right now, fucking, how desperate, wait, is it baked on,
mods, hang drawn for that wiefling, okay a bit dramatic, but no,
nope she's online at nine a.m, oh freaking the screw, mods smack that man silly,
you could read Maid Mint, is that not inappropriate of me to do that though,
she's playing out her words,
is that inappropriate to do, I don't know, I feel like it's inappropriate when it's like a big
Vtuber, they're just like, do you know Pillowdeer, oh Pillowdeer's an ASMR, hold on a minute, Pillowdeer's
an ASMRist, and she's playing Minecraft, why my darling, okay Pillowdeer's getting it because
she does ASMR, um, she does it, oh for fuck's sake she's playing Minecraft with that fucking
inappropriate server that I can't interact with, okay Mint Maid is, so Mint Maid is,
congrats Mint Maid, I'm going to interrupt your stream with a host of randy wieflings,
oh goodness gravy, I'm trying, okay please do be super respectful when I redirect into Mint Maid,
and we got there in the end, we found someone,
there we go, there she is, Outer Wales, I've actually never played Outer Wales,
Fellas are good to play, Pillowdeer's super wholesome, yeah, and of course she's playing a
Minecraft server that I can't interact with, so out of respect I can't interact with, so I might
leave them to it, let them enjoy their thing, and so we'll redirect into Mint Maid, are you guys
gonna be okay? Okay as long as you guys are okay, Outer Wales is incredible, we should keep our
tentacles for ourselves, yes please do behave, please don't be a goobie McGoober face,
and because you're not comfortable with your bed, I don't know how other streamers are,
like you know how streamers like, don't backseat game, I'm like,
literally just carry me through entire games, everyone's, different strokes for everyone's
different pickle or something like that, okay, okay, right, rest well little brieflings, I am
about to go make a cup of tea and get a cola, and then we'll do a membership brighten stream,
and we'll see if you guys like it or not, and then after that I will be taking a break, and then
I'll be back online for Yumi Plus, yumi yumi ye, yumi ye, yumi ye, sualalala, okay,
bye bye, see you later alligator, see you on mungus, okay, bye bye